يعيش في قطاع غزه نحو اكثر من مليونين
نسمه على مساحه لا تزيد على
365 كيلومترا مربعا ويقسمون على اربعه
واربعين تجمعا سكنيا بمعدل كثافه تقدر
بسته وعشرين الف فرد لكل كيلومتر مربع في
المدن وخمسه وخمسين الف نسمه لكل كيلومتر
مربع في المخيمات وهذا يشكل خللا في نمط
الاسره الفلسطينيه في ظل توزيع عشوائي
للسكان والاعمار والاراضي من قبل السلطات
في غزه حيث يتركز في المنطقه الغربيه
الساحليه وهي منطقه زراعيه مهمه ومن
الافضل ان يكون السكن والاعمار في المنطقه
الشرقيه لانها منطقه قليله المياه ولا
تصلح للزراعه ما يهدد سلامه الامن الغذائي
في غزه جزء من هذه الاراضي ما زالت اراضي
الزراعيه ليس هناك اراضي سكنيه بشكل كبير
يمكن ان ننبه حاجه السكان اضافه الى ذلك
نحن نتحدث اساسا عن عجز في الوحدات
السكنيه في قطاع غزه وحاله الفقر وحاله
البطاله التي يعيش فيها سكان قطاع غزه ادى
الى ظهور حاله من العشوائيات في بعض
المناطق المتاخمه للمدن والقرى وبلدات
الفلسطينيه وبالتالي بدانا نرى حاله اسكان
عشوائي قائم على اسكان مؤقت في بعض الاسر
المحتاجه والمعوزه في هذه المناطق وفي
غياب واضح من قبل الجهات المسؤوله عن وضع
استراتيجيه لمعالجه ازمه السكن في قطاع
غزه وازمه الاسر الفقيره والبطاله والفقر
لدينا احتياج للوحدات السكنيه يزيد عن 100
الف وحده سكنيه
واحتياج سنوي طبيعي
قرابه 14 الف وحده سكنيه نتيجه التزايد في
عدد بشكل طبيعي اضافه الى ذلك هناك هدم
متكرر من الاحتلال الاسرائيلي لمنازل
المواطنين والامنين هناك هدم للابراج
السكنيه لم يتم اعاده اعمارها حتى الان
هناك الفين وحده سكنيه لم يتم اعمارها حتى
الان نتيجه العدوان المتكرر على قطاع غزه